i would sit down with the engineers the
developers of the software and say
explain this to me so that i completely
understood it
and only then could i write about it
because
i mean if you've ever tried to explain
something you don't understand
it doesn't work right but if you
understand it you can take
what is complex and make it simple
[Music]
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
for joining me how are you
i'm good thanks for having me and for
inviting me of course thank you where
are you calling from right now
i'm in the san francisco bay area i live
in marin county just north of san
francisco
wonderful it's a beautiful beautiful
area i really enjoyed going hiking there
before covert and hopefully after covet
as well
more than 30 years of experience in the
tech and software industry
but it all starts with nothing else but
a major in drama in french
how does that happen exactly
how does that happen i'm not quite sure
but i'll tell you i'll tell you the
brief story of how it all went down
so i got out of university with a degree
in drama in french and
you know realized that being an actor
which i aspired to be is a really hard
work
and i hated going to auditions and i
realized that wasn't for me
so i had to get a job my first job out
of school was being a french teacher but
soon after that i got a job at the
french trade commission in new york city
where i was living when they introduced
computers for the first time
and i it turned out yeah this is going
way way back this
dates me i'm more than twice your age i
think michael but this was like the
original pcs uh the ibm pcs back in the
80s
and it turned out i was a quick study
and i
um i learned how to use them i figured
out how to use them pretty well
but what i was really good at was
explaining how to use them to the people
who didn't understand and who were kind
of scared by
and so that led me that was sort of the
crucial
step in my career that led me to the
tech industry i
decided to leave new york back in the
late 80s and moved to california where
i'd grown up in the bay area and i um
decided based on advice from a friend
that i was going to try to become a
technical writer because what technical
writers do is actually translate
technical information into something
digestible and understandable by a lay
person and so
this is like 1989 time frame
and i was applying to the very few
software companies that were around
and one of them happened to be adobe and
so
back in 1989 i'm having this interview
at adobe
and they're asking me questions like
what do you know about
print reproduction and photography and
the answer out to all of those questions
was i know nothing
but they hired me to be a technical
writer and my first assignment was
to write the tutorial for photoshop
version 1.0
no really seriously yes
yes and if you give me a minute i'll
probably i have a copy here i'm sure
i'll pull it out of my drawer
wow that is so cool can you see that
yeah wow that was 1989 it actually came
out in 1990 so that was my first job in
tech
you you wrote a book basically that was
your first published book
exactly exactly and i wrote several
after
for photoshop and illustrator and
premiere and all sorts of adobe products
and then
and then what happened after that is
because i was young and it was
early days and there was so much going
on in silicon valley as i
moved around from company to company so
i went from
adobe to symantec um actually
that's not the order i went from adobe
to efi
to a startup symantec and then finally
autodesk so i basically
in 10 years from 89 to 99 i was a
technical writer at five different
companies in the valley
and then in 99 i i landed at autodesk
and i ended up staying at autodesk for
20 years
right
so talk to me about this crazy journey
because you you end up
as vice president at autodesk which is
incredible by itself but i bet it's
but it's always the journey that's even
more impressive so talk to me about the
different
stepping blogs that you've gone through
during your time at autodesk
well as i said i started as a writer
back in 99 and what happened
pretty soon after i started is that my
manager
decided that she wanted me to be a
manager she said she needed a manager
she needed someone to manage the writers
and she saw a potential in me uh for
leadership and management and
i hadn't aspired to that at all michael
i was just you know i was happy doing
writing
and yet i said well i'll give it a try
she kind of twisted my arm
and so i started being a manager of
other technical writers
and then it turned out i love that
because i'm very much a people person
and i love the
figuring out how people tick and that
everyone's different and that
you can't manage you know 10 different
people in the same way and so
i got into management and and then i did
that for several years
leading the technical writers and then i
decided i was bored
and you know i'd been doing technical
writing for 10 years
and i'd managed writers for a few more
years and i'm like i want to learn
something totally new this is
kind of how i am when i that's why i
moved around so much for those those
first 10 years i just wanted to learn
new things so
i started looking around for a new job
both
inside of autodesk and outside and it
turned out there was this really
interesting job
internally to lead a team of engineers
um
who were managing our software for
localization
so for those of you who don't know
localization is actually getting
everything translated and ready
for international markets and there's
this very specific software that they
were managing
that was really complex and they needed
a new
manager for the team so i applied for
that job and
that was for me a real stepping stone
because you know going from managing
writers where i could do the work to
managing engineers where i couldn't do
the work that they did
was a real big you know jump for me and
i had to
you know interview with a zillion people
to get that job and and i
and i got it so that was my first job
out of my comfort zone really
that that's incredible and now i have to
understand a little bit better this
process of being a technical writer
and for example taking the photoshop
version 1.0
a guide for the layperson well
talk to me a little bit about that
process i don't think neither myself nor
most of my friends know really what what
goes into
writing these guides so so how does that
process actually look
yeah and you know what's so interesting
i mean even the terminology i don't
think we even use the term technical
writer anymore it's often
content designer content developer is
much more common now
right he's often seen as part of design
and ux and all of that but
but back in the day we call it technical
writing but what it really is and
you know you have all you and everyone
else whoever listens to this
has experienced bad technical writing
it's when you buy something and you get
the instructions
and you can't follow them or they're
just plain wrong or they don't make
sense
what what good technical writing is is
that the writer sits down and truly
learns the software
like inside and out or whatever it is
hardware software i spent so my process
was
i would learn everything i could on my
own i would read whatever specifications
i would play with the software
but then i would sit down with the
engineers the developers of the software
and say explain this to me
so that i completely understood it and
only then
could i write about it because i mean if
you've ever tried to explain something
you don't understand
it doesn't work right but if you
understand it
you can take what is complex and make it
simple
and i think people i mean this is one of
the things i really learned and as i got
better as a writer is
how can you take something infinitely
complicated
and make it as simple as possible and
that was always my goal
now one of your you mentioned to me
before this
that you know going back to your major
drama in french
it kind of played an interesting role in
your career
as it was unfolding into the different
perspectives and
and the skill sets that you had while
they didn't seem to align with the
positions and what you had to
or you had to use they they actually
were pretty beneficial
tell me a little bit about how that came
about yeah i thought about that over the
years because it's not necessarily
obvious but
you know one thing i think is whenever
you study and learn a
foreign language and i lived in france
and i'm really fluent in french so i was
able to
immerse myself in another language and
culture i think that makes you just
much more adaptable to
different cultures and different
perspectives because you've learned to
think in another language
i think that really helps in just i mean
i've worked in very international
companies so
working with people from different
cultures whose first language is not
english and
so to me it's always about communicating
clearly trying to understand the other
person i think that has really
served me well and then from drama i
mean drama is one of these
underestimated skills i think because
you know certainly acting you learn to
you learn to listen to the other person
you learn to improvise because
unexpected things happen
you learn to communicate in both verbal
and non-verbal ways
and you learn i think the thing that um
certainly stage acting and i know
i never did you know film but i know
this is true it's such a collaborative
process
you know the actor is only as good as
the director and the lighting and the
costumes and everything else
and what i loved about theater is the
collaborative nature of it and
i really saw the parallels in developing
software because
software is not just the software
developer it's the designer it's the
product manager it's the marketing
people and the sales people and those
technical writers and the qa people and
all of that is what makes a great
product and that's the same in theater
all of those skills are transferable i i
have to look back you know to my
high school days i was a huge musical
theater geek i still am
a musical theater fan but i used to take
part in every musical and every play
that we had in school my
my dream as a child was to be an an
actor on stage for the rest of my life i
turned out that i
that i fell in love with computers and
software and so that's where i'm i'm at
now but
but looking back uh i i see it in every
single aspect of my life i see it in my
relationships i see it in the way that i
i communicate with people this
collaborative nature of what you're
saying and you mentioned that
you're only as good as as you are as a
group and
being on stage remember in the shows you
know we were kids we made mistakes all
the time somebody would forget their
lines in the middle of the play
or this prop would fall from the sky and
you
we would find ourselves in this
situation where we realize that you know
we can't look good
if we distance ourselves from the
problem we have to go at it together
and if we try to distance ourselves
we're only doing harm both to ourselves
and to
and to everybody else and so i i really
really appreciate this
insight and i couldn't agree more with
it yeah so
so it's not obvious that drama and
french are the perfect preparation to
eventually become vp of engineering as a
software company
but in my mind it couldn't have been
better honestly so if anybody's
listening to this from stanford and
they're studying cs
consider moving to the drama or foreign
language departments and
you'll you'll get it perhaps to the same
spot
but along the way you you make this
pretty radical transition from being
vice president at an amazing company
like autodesk
to a starting to speak to others and to
share some of the key insights
that you've gained along your career
some of it is about compassion
about empathy about acceptance so what
are what are some of those insights
well i think i have to backtrack a
little bit uh to tell you how i got to
that so um you know we sort of stopped
with my career at
i got to manage some engineers and then
many years went by and i ended up taking
on
a series of other leadership positions
in the company but
to get to that vp of engineering job i
had i had gotten to a senior director
role i led a big department in the
company
but to get to that vp role i had to
uh basically that the guy who was hiring
for that role
said you know minette you know you've
got a great track record here i know
you're a good leader
but you have two strikes against you and
he was very clear about those two
strikes you said one
you were never an engineer so you have
to gain credibility with the engineering
community
because you know although you've been in
tech and you are technical you were
you weren't the one developing software
so you've got to gain credibility
and two he said you're a woman and the
engineering leadership here is a boys
club
and so you're going to have to break
into the boys club and so
what happened is i did not get the job
right away i had to do a 90-day trial
and during those 90 days yeah i did an
acting role so i was acting vp for three
months
and yeah and during those three months i
basically had to win the endorsements of
all the engineering leaders in the
company
and they happened at that time to be all
men
wow so you were acting vp for three
months you had to get the acceptance of
that boys club
okay that's that's incredible go on so
i i did i have i mean it's a long story
but i eventually i did get i did get
that role and i did that role for about
five years
and during the time and my my goal
what i was basically assigned to do was
to transform engineering at autodesk
which is you can imagine a huge task it
says it was a 10
i was about 9 000 people when i was
there about 3 500 engineers
and i realized you know none of this is
a technical problem
none i mean we had a lot of issues we
had all these different you know
platforms and
we had to really consolidate tools but
it was a behavioral
issue it was a people issue and it was a
call it was culture it was all about
culture and how we behaved
and i got as in that role is like yeah i
can i had
great staff i had very technical people
working under me but what i needed to do
was really talk about
how are we going to behave differently
how are we going to collaborate
how are we going to work more
effectively together and so i got myself
a
big education really through reading and
you know being online and just reading a
zillion books
about human behavior and um and i also
became a real advocate for women and for
people of color because
even though i am a white woman i was
very much in the minority because you
know engineering is so male and so
i often felt other i often felt like i
didn't fit in
like i wasn't included and and i wanted
to change that
and so when i finally left autodesk
after 20 years i left last year
i realized you know autodesk is a great
company but they're struggling with this
all the companies
are struggling with inclusion you know
diversity inclusion and equity
and so i wanted to bring my perspective
and my experience
and help others do better around this
because honestly everyone's struggling
and everyone needs help with it
minette you're you're vice president of
the engineering space
3 500 engineers at autodesk and you're
coming you're saying talking about how
this is a behavioral problem
it's culture at the end and of course
you know in 2020 we've seen
and not just in tech but around the
world how how big of a
of a part culture plays into our life
and into our
our ability to to thrive as just as a
planet right
and as a global community and i i'd love
for you to share a little bit more
into the insights of what how do you
build
a healthy culture in you know both in
in large large corporation like autodesk
but also in a small startup
and i'm looking specifically you know
it's selfish insights for me as i'm
about to start my own entrepreneurial
journey or for my friends that are in
their journey
what are some key insights that you've
gained about behavior and about culture
and diversity and inclusion
yeah well there's there's so much
and you know it's kind of hard to know
where to start but what i will say is
that
the leaders really set the tone
and i think especially you know big
companies and small but when you're a
startup
um often and i've seen this so much
startups go we're going really fast
we're going to build something really
cool we're going to get it out there
we're going to try to get investment
we're going to try to get customers
and then later even you know even with a
startup they'll say
oh look we're all men now we got to hire
some women and how are we going to do
that and
and it's almost too late even if you're
just a handful of men because
do the women want to come work there do
the people of color want to come here
so i think that whether you're larger or
small starting up or a 30 year old
company
you need to be intentional and the
leaders need to set the tone of
being inclusive and what that means in
terms of leadership and this is a lot of
the work that i do is that
leaders are not omniscient and they need
to admit what they don't know they need
to be vulnerable
they need to be open to listening and
honestly
that is so much of what i think the
problem is right now is that people
don't know how to listen
to their diverse employees and and to
hear their true experiences
because i've experienced this myself a
senior executive
will say don't bring me problems bring
me solutions
but honestly you need to hear the
problems before you can even attempt
the solutions and you need to be
uncomfortable
with that listening you need to be
willing to be uncomfortable
and to say i don't have all the answers
but i'm i'm willing to listen and i'm
going to make sure
that this is a safe place where
everyone's voice can be heard
and to me that is the number one thing
is that we have to we have to make it
safe and
people do not feel safe today speaking
up and telling their truth
right right and i love your take on
being intentional about it as a leader
and being vocal about it and and being
willing to be uncomfortable with
with the problem and not just sugar
coating it or
shrugging it aside i think i think it's
wonderful how do you
then make the impact now so you've left
autodesk part of
part of the motivation from what i'm
hearing from you is
understand that you've you've made an
incredible impact at your
company ultimates but you're then this
is a global problem
along with many companies and you're now
looking to make that impact there so
how do you go about doing that yeah
well i started my own consulting
business this summer during covet week
because what else do you do during
coverage right
right i mean i i i took a break and then
realized that's what i wanted to do
but i've also for many years even when i
was at autodesk i was a keynote speaker
internally and externally so i've been
doing recently a fair number of keynotes
that
there's a real appetite to hear about
diversity and inclusion and so i have
i had one last month i have one this
next friday so i'm trying to get the
board out but i
i do have a new client and it's a
startup and they're
they're realizing that they may have an
issue with equity and with inclusion and
so
we're just starting the conversations
and so i'm doing both you know like
just the one-on-one engagements with
smaller large companies and that's just
starting
and then i'm also giving talks because i
feel like people just need to hear and
and one of the things is that you know i
will be honest in those talks i'm not
going to sugarcoat things and
say that it's all perfect and i'll share
my own experiences as well
i love that minette i want to thank you
for being so generous with your time
and before we go i have to ask the most
important question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
all right um i have to start with
authentic
because you only get you only get one
minute i don't have different personas
for different environments it's
i'm always going to be real so authentic
empathetic
i can't even turn off my empathy and
that's both a blessing and a curse so
if you start crying it's likely that i'm
going to be crying with you
but you know that's just that's just who
i am and then
the third is i don't know if i would say
energetic or enthusiastic i'll go with
enthusiastic because
i've just got a lot of i've got so much
oomph and i have so much i want to share
and i want to help people and
i want to get at it wonderful minnett
thank you so much this is wonderful
and continue making a positive impact
and helping companies
regain the eco the equity and diverse
nature that
they all deserve and we all deserve and
and i look forward to
to seeking your advice and when i'm
starting my own venture to make sure
that i
properly i'm leading by example and
being intentional about it so thank you
thank you i would love to continue that
with you michael thanks so much
take care